[Music]
tonight we're talking about climate and
this is this is something you know
weather is the thing that happens
short-term and climate is a longer scale
thing I'm reminded because the Edward
Burtynsky who's a past speaker for us
and who actually with his new project
the Anthropocene film which is coming
out later this year
sponsored this series sponsored our
livestream we've got members watching by
a livestream right now so the trailer
for that film is out there now and I
recommend checking it out and it shows
the way that our activity on this planet
has impacted the planet over time our
industries our our our pleasures our
wars in in every way we are now a factor
in how the planet changes and so it's
something you know Stewart brands line
is that we are as gods and need to get
good at it being aware of it and being
considerate of it is the first step
towards doing something proactive so our
talk tonight we're going to talk about
the current situation or a climate
perspective and some of the things that
we could do may do and it's going to be
a great chance to look at some of those
possibilities going forward our speaker
Kelly wander is currently executive
director of silver lining which is an
advocacy group that is working to ensure
safety for people and ecosystems by
driving options to reduce atmospheric
heat she was previously a co-director of
the marine cloud brightening
at the University of Washington as which
she testified in US Congress for the
house space and Space Science and
Technology Committee and last year she
was also an advisor to the Ocean
Conservancy Conservancy and on the
president circle of the National Academy
of Sciences and yeah let's let's see
what what we can see from this vantage
points about what's in front of us now
and in front of us long term as we look
at climate the big round of applause for
Kelly thank you for the applause you can
see how friends I'm really touched to be
here and I want to thank Michael and the
interval team and long now they become
something of a home for me and they're a
big part of the work that I've been
doing for the past few years which I
will describe and just to give you a
little background on myself I'm not a
scientist I spent a couple of decades in
IT infrastructure working in areas of
messaging security and networks so I
like complex systems problems and I'm
interested in problems with big
implications and about 10 years ago I
became concerned about climate and as a
sort of passion effort I got to know a
couple of people in the area Steve
Schneider amazing climate scientist who
passed away a few years ago and Ken
caldera also based at Stanford at
Carnegie Institution who is a mentor of
mine and getting to know these topics
and understanding them a little bit
better so I've been very fortunate being
here in the Bay Area to get an
introduction to this type of work and to
get to know some of the preeminent
people in the fields well talk about in
the course of this talk it's a big topic
and so I I will be going through some
pretty big ideas pretty quickly so
please store up your questions at the
end
I've got permission to keep going as
long as we need to
as far as questions go but this is
really about looking at the severity of
our climate situation so I'm going to
start off by characterizing the sort of
a challenge that we've got in sort of
lining things up in terms of time and
space and then talk a little bit about
what people are proposing with regard to
you know near-term options for
addressing heat risk and then finally
I'll talk a little bit about the state
of play where we are and where we might
need to go in order to understand and
pursue any of these kinds of
alternatives so with that said I will
start with a quote from the eminent
thinker or Michael Crichton which is the
planet is not in jeopardy we are in
jeopardy and so in the spirit of long
now I kind of want to set the context in
terms of the planet that we live on and
the planet that we live on is
tremendously complex
I just learned from NPR recently that
there are more bacteria on earth than
there are considered to be stars in the
universe so we have this incredibly
complex diverse abundant system makes it
incredibly unique in the universe and a
little bit difficult to understand and
predict both in the natural system and
in the intelligent species that live on
it so we have a complex systems problem
and complex systems problems are
characterized by their difficulty in
prediction and they're characterized by
the emergence of the emergence of new
things and the death of other things and
so they're quite hard to understand and
they're they're quite hard to manage but
we have some experience in trying to
understand and manage complex systems
which I will talk about but I want to
put this in the context of Earth and
this is a temperature history of the
planet a really nice graph and you can
see that it's not totally linear so the
Holocene optimum which is the period
that we live in
is stretched out a little bit on the
chart but what you'll notice is that we
live in this period of incredible sort
of temperature stability and it's
allowed the flourishing of a lot of the
diversity and abundance that we know and
so what you see in the picture is you
know a floral composition made by
butterflies and so we live in this sort
of delicate space that is a combination
of stable temperature sorry I was
looking at butterflies and you weren't
there you go there are the butterflies
so so all of this abundance and delicate
diversity is enabled by reasonably
stable temperature and rich biodiversity
and you can see from the chart this is
actually quite rare in the history of
Earth and to the best of our knowledge
it's rare in the universe and maybe
completely unique so in this sort of
spirit of thinking long term we have
potentially a unique situation in all of
history in all of the universe and it's
a delicate one that we're in and we as
the intelligent species on the planet
have been acting on the system
and one of the things that we've been
doing is adding material pulling
material from the ground and adding it
into the air in a way that's increasing
the amount of heat that the atmosphere
stores and so you can see here in these
two we've got a couple of charts that
show the increases since industrial
times of co2 and methane released into
the atmosphere and the famous Keeling
chart that shows the atmospheric
concentrations and going up so from
pre-industrial times we've kind of from
industrial times it causes sort of
dramatic uptick and what's coming into
the atmosphere of the stores heat and
then in more recent times you can see
where that's where that's gone in terms
of the past sort of thousand years and
what's projected going forward into 2100
so you can see in this chart here sorry
my eyes are failing me a little bit so
we've got the past hundred years and
we're seeing what that's doing to
temperatures and you start to see this
rise especially in the past 30 years
global average temperature
and then this chart on the on your right
is the IPCC projections of what happens
to temperature based on current trends
and the red line is called business as
usual and that's actually the line that
we're on and so the other lines the blue
line which shows kind of a curve and a
stabilization is the most optimistic
assumptions about what we might be able
to do to keep temperature stable and I'm
going to talk a little bit later about
what they're thinking but in terms of
our state as a complex system one way to
think about the Earth's system as a
biological system like the human body
and there are a lot of similarities to
use human body with a fever where we can
handle some amount of spike and fever
but if the fever continues and it
continues to rise in various parts of
the system can start to change and they
can start to change permanently so right
now we have a fever and we want to take
a look at what the fever is projected to
do to different parts of your system so
these are some of my favorite kids
my godson is the one with the Rubik's
Cube my niece and nephew there and so
around 2050 these kids will be in their
30s which if you have kids that you know
this will be true of them also so when I
walk you through some of what's
projected for the earth system around
2050 and and this isn't primarily based
on climate model predictions like we
used to this is looking at striations of
what's happening to the system now and
this tends to come from scientists and
researchers that are looking at
different parts of the system
individually and so firstly we have a
projection that the amount of forest
burn area in the United States will be
10 times what it was in 1970 so today
it's about three times what it was in
1970 and so it's tracking along the
temperature rise so two or three decades
from now we can anticipate lots more
forest fires than we have today
alongside that going on at the same time
we'll have the effects of heat on the
ocean and the one that we hear a lot
about is a heat effect on coral reefs
coral reefs support 25 percent of life
in the ocean
currently they're being killed by heat
stress they're sensitive to heat big
heat waves are coming
we've lost somewhere between a quarter
and a half of the coral reefs in the
world already and they support a big
portion of ocean life so we don't know
yet quite what happens when we lose that
life and the ocean is a really complex
highly interconnected system and so heat
stress on the ocean could have effects
that we can't fully predict in terms of
what happens to other life in the ocean
and the links between the ocean in the
atmosphere so there's a form of life
that grows at the surf and surface of
the ocean called phytoplankton and that
biological life is quite important to
feeding the fish below and it also
handles interaction between the ocean in
the atmosphere I call it the API layer
between the ocean in the atmosphere so
it takes in co2 fort of interpret so
what's happening in the ocean it's
produced by the the ocean food web and
then it interacts with the atmosphere it
takes in co2 it releases gases that help
form clouds and it's very important to
our system currently phytoplankton we're
losing at a rate about one percent a
year or sorry a decade and it's thought
that in the past few since 1950 we may
have lost as much as 40 percent of the
phytoplankton on the ocean so we have to
watch for things like this in terms of
the whole system another thing we have
to watch for is collapse of ice sheets
and Antarctica this is a picture by
Chris Michael Chris where are you who
has many wonderful Antarctic pictures
there and and can talk to you about what
it's like to go to Antarctica many times
and so if if those ice sheets were to
collapse as they are predicted when
temperatures approach around 1.9 degrees
then we might see some big changes some
big abrupt changes in sea level in sea
level rise and in the nature of the
current circulation in the ocean and the
major a mock Curran
so again these kinds of things are
predicted to happen around 1.9 degrees
and as we saw in a previous chart we're
looking at that around the middle of
this century based on what's happening
and again concurrent with those things
we have effects on infrastructure so one
of the things to think about when we
think about climate change especially
when it comes to discussion of
adaptation is we're likely to have lots
of things going on at once and a lot of
our infrastructure was built to a
certain range of conditions of
temperature of wind a storm surge of
ground conditions and we're starting to
push the climate outside of the
conditions that some of that
infrastructure was built for so these
are two charts the chart on the Left
shows the vulnerability of bridges in
the United States and it's forecast that
by 2050 about half the bridges in the
United States will be vulnerable meaning
they need reengineering half the bridges
in the United States and the other chart
is looking at the vulnerability of
coastal military infrastructure which is
something that the military takes pretty
seriously and you can see an enormous
amount of vulnerability to flooding of
that infrastructure or making possibly
rendering some of some of those sites
unviable so and those are just a couple
of examples and I'm I'm not here to
necessarily raise alarms but what I want
to do is say can we think rationally and
logically about the set of conditions
that we're facing and the kinds of
options that we might need to look at
because heat stress is something that
creates a number of big changes and big
challenges concurrently that could lead
to a lot of suffering for people and a
lot of your reversible changes in our
natural systems good news
we're in Silicon Valley and I'm lucky
because I know the head of research at
the slack and lots of people in venture
capital and people at Stanford at the
Precourt Institute and Berkeley where
they're working on energy solutions and
the things that are coming in
pipeline in terms of energy materials
capturing carbon are extraordinary I am
a techno and I believe that by the end
of the century it's absolutely possible
that we could have solutions to waste to
energy to food production that allow the
sustainable sustainable healthy happy
life for people on this planet for years
to come and big natural systems that
sustain themselves too so the question
is how does that look in terms of kind
of the timeline to our solutions and so
this is a chart that's based on IPCC
information and the United Nations
environmental program showing what we
would have to do to maintain temperature
below two degrees with the tools that we
have at our disposal today so based on
emissions reduction alone we would need
to start moving to zero emissions by
2030 which is 12 years from now in order
to stay below two degrees zero emissions
zero net emissions by 2030 so that
doesn't look very likely based on what
it takes to transition energy production
and other things so then we introduced
in the IPCC has introduced the notion of
removing carbon from the atmosphere so
actively finding mechanisms that can
filter the air bring down carbon finding
more ways to actively plant organic
material trees and other things that
will pull carbon out of the air actively
and so what they've done in IPCC
projections as they've said if we have
these things then it is possible to
extend the time that we have to safely
stay under two degrees but you'll notice
from the chart that these requires
starting to implement these negative
emissions technologies now and and
scaling them up very rapidly and the
folks in and around the IPCC will will
admit that these things do not exist yet
and they haven't they haven't been fully
analyzed even
notion of planting trees more
aggressively in a in a certain type of
way in order to increase their our co2
absorption so we have a challenge that
we have a pipeline of capabilities that
in the future could lead to a zero
emissions world and a way that we can
reclaim greenhouse gases from the air
but we don't have them today typically
it takes about 50 years
to transform infrastructure and replace
it so we have some period of time
between today and the future where we
have you know a disruptive set of
technologies that we need we're right in
the middle of that that time span that
we talked about around the middle of
this century 2050 we have a bit of a
problem because that's when big system
changes might occur that create a lot of
suffering for people and potentially set
off reactions that we can't control so
we're in a position or we could be in a
position a couple decades from now where
we've got a sort of more intensive care
type situation and we may need to
consider more active interventions for
treatment than we would otherwise do
this cartoon also references the sort of
disparity between what's being proposed
at the global level this is
sustainability goals which include
keeping people out of poverty access to
energy education and things that make
life comfortable alongside
a sustainable environment and safe
climate and so this particular cartoon
is saying you have to give up on these
types of goals and what you really need
to do is ratchet back economic growth
and there are people who think that
that's the way we're going to accomplish
what we need and so this sort of
scenario that first scenario that I
showed you sort of implies a lot of
ratcheting back among other things
but we might postulate that maybe there
was a bridge to the future that
accommodates human nature limits
suffering and allows us to get through
this period where we have a bit of a
societal and technical gap and we need
to keep heat we need to keep heat under
control so this is a quote from Mark
Twain everybody complains about the
weather nobody does anything about it so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what Michael referred to as global the
global long term weather or climate and
what you can see here this is a
simulation from NASA of clouds and
aerosols so clouds and aerosols are
wonderful there are a really key
component of our atmosphere and weather
they're one of the major ways that the
earth keeps itself cool so this
Goldilocks zone that we live in is in a
large part created by the fact that our
atmosphere not only traps heat but it
reflects light away and so what you see
here are clouds and aerosols bouncing
light off the surface and reflecting it
back out into space and this is very
much part of what nature does and all
those cloud and aerosol interactions are
created by particles that waft up from
the ground and they waft up from wind on
the land and they waft up from the ocean
spray and they mix into the atmosphere
and they stay as particles and they
create clouds and they do this wonderful
cooling of the planet so the idea that
arose a few decades ago that was first
propagated by Paul Crutzen
in 1987 and Paul Crutzen you may know as
the person who won the Nobel Prize for
identifying the ozone hole and the risk
that we had there so he postulated the
idea that we might be able to use this
kind of effect for cooling the planet in
the context of climate change and he
thought that was something you might
need so the effect that we're talking
about and I'm gonna trade for the
pointer here for a second so the effect
that we're talking about there are two
types of reflective effects that
particles can create in the atmosphere
one is when they
float up in the atmosphere and let light
bounces off the particles directly we
tend to call that a scattering light
scattering effect and you see mist in
the sky and light will bounce off of
that back into space
the other type of effect is when small
particles mix in with clouds and what
they tend to do if they're the right
type of particle is they'll attract
water from the droplets that are in the
clouds
to themselves and they'll they'll create
a larger number of smaller particles
within the cloud making the cloud wider
and and fluffier looking brighter
looking and it will also make the cloud
last longer and you can kind of
intuitively know this because when the
droplets in the clouds start to congeal
the cloud gradually gets darker and when
they get big enough they fall out as
rain so those are the two effects the
direct scattering effect and what we
call the cloud aerosol effect that
scientists postulate we might be able to
leverage actively and slightly modify
the reflectivity of the atmosphere so
I'm going to show you now a highly
technical drawing over here this is
actually a moderately accurate and I'll
explain where it's accurate and where
it's not a depiction of the two most
promising thought to be the most
promising approaches to slightly
increasing the reflectivity of the
atmosphere and how much reflectivity we
might need in order to in order to
neutralize the heat effects of
greenhouse gases so so what happened a
few years ago first the Royal Society in
the UK and then the National Academy of
Sciences in the u.s. they each looked at
various proposals for trying to engineer
or climate engineer ways of removing
greenhouse gases and engineer ways of
increasing the reflection of sunlight to
bring heat out in the atmosphere
directly and in both cases they went
through things like ping-pong balls on
the ocean and plastic sheets on ice and
mirrors and space and they evaluated
these techniques for their sort of
feasibility and and potential viability
they they identified a couple of them
that seemed the most relevant for
further research and those were the ones
that that sort of mimicked certain
naturally observed phenomenon to change
the reflectivity of the atmosphere and
so the two that they focused on were one
that you've probably heard about a lot
which is putting particles in the
stratosphere the particle of these
particles are not actual size so they're
very tiny you wouldn't be able to see
them probably possibly not even as a
contrail quite tiny particles so the
idea here is putting particles in the
stratosphere to reflect sunlight
directly this direct scattering effect
and I'll explain a little bit more about
that because I've got lots more pictures
to show you and then the other is the
idea of brightening clouds and the
troposphere and in this case brightening
clouds of the ocean using a mist of sea
salt from ocean water so generating tiny
particles of sea salt from the water
misting into otherwise I'm polluted
clouds over the ocean and in a
concentrated way actually reflecting a
lot of sunlight back out into space so
I'll explain those two now and further
detail because there have been some
active efforts to study them and they
start with studying some of the natural
processes that are similar to what
happens
so this first this first slide that I'm
showing you is showing the effects of
cloud aerosol cooling today so one thing
that many people are aren't aware of is
that we are already brightening the
atmosphere with particles with man-made
particles from human emissions and we're
doing this today in the lower atmosphere
that we call the troposphere and we're
primarily largely doing it by
brightening clouds but we also have the
direct effect so this chart here is a
famous chart that you may have seen
that's showing the different sources of
warming and cooling in the atmosphere
generated by human activity and so the
bars shooting off to your right are the
ones that show where heat
forcing is coming from so you see co2
other greenhouse gases primarily methane
and we've got something of a competing
effect of what ozone does in the
troposphere versus the stratosphere and
then we have these other bars here which
are shooting off to the left which are
actually a cooling effect and you can
see this black line here is
demonstrating how much uncertainty there
is you can see there's quite a lot of
uncertainty as to how big that cooling
effect is and that cooling effect is
coming from that direct scattering of
particles and the mixing with clouds and
it's thought to be between 0.5 and 1
point 2 degrees C so let that sink in
our pollution is cooling the planet
today somewhere between 0.5 and 1 point
2 degrees C and we're likely to lose a
lot of that effect as we bring down
emissions and it's a pretty big gap in
what we know about how big that effect
is so that idea is related to one of you
proposals for brightening the atmosphere
to generate cooling so this is a picture
of the Pacific West Coast the United
States and the streaks that you see in
the clouds are actually created by
emissions from ships and so this idea of
what they call ship tracks in
atmospheric science was actually
postulated by scientists in the 40s
before they had the ability to observe
them and once they set up satellites in
the 60s and 70s they were able to see
that actually their theory was true and
that particulates from ship emissions
mostly sulfates from bunker fuels
brightened clouds today the the total
amount of shipping emissions over the
ocean is thought to cool the planet and
we're about to do an experiment on this
because in 2020 we will reduce the
amount of those emissions by about 85
percent under new IMO regulations which
is very good for the health of people on
shore moderately good for greenhouse
gases although they're really focused on
the particulates so if we were in a
position to measure it which we probably
are not we might see a
bump in warming of between of 0.12 point
two degrees C from losing this cooling
mask so based on that idea one proposal
that was first postulated by a British
researcher named John Latham and a
Scottish genius engineer named Steve
Salter and that is his that is not a
real ship that is a theoretical wind
powered flettner rotor ship but the idea
is that you would take water from the
ocean distill it generate tiny particles
of mostly salt with a little bit of
water into a mist and those particles
would be about 80 nanometers in size so
a little bit like what comes out of an
asthma inhaler and you would need to
generate 10 to the 16th particles per
second so quite a big volume and you
would navigate them around the ocean and
you would look for big banks of the type
of clouds that are susceptible to
brightening in this way sir in free
exist in 3 or 4 parts of the world and
where are you to brighten those clouds
maybe six or seven percent brighter then
they stored it out you might be able to
offset a doubling of co2 or a couple of
degrees of warming you might be able to
do that and that would represent about
twenty to thirty percent of marine
clouds or about four to five percent of
the surface area of the ocean so that is
one idea that idea because this approach
is temporary and localized you might
also postulate doing things at a scale
below the scale of the entire planet
we're cooling might create a helpful
effect and so one of the things that
researchers would like to look at but
haven't had the resources to do is
whether or not there would be approaches
to cooling ocean surface temperatures in
the Gulf Atlantic region in theory were
you to cool ocean surface temperatures
for the few months before hurricane
season you might be able to reduce the
force of hurricanes and that sort of
physics is relatively well-known because
of the role
heat in the system but we know actually
quite little about whether or not this
would work
and similarly with coral reefs so heat
stress is definitely approximate
stressed coral reefs it's happening all
over the world this is a recent chart of
the alert level associated with coral
populations around the world and it's
it's a very sort of stark in dire story
so it's possible that there might be
some parts of the world or cloud and
atmospheric conditions making make it
possible to cool ocean temperatures in a
way that helps sustain corals against
heat stress and the National Academy of
Sciences is currently doing a study on
sustaining corals and they've included
any and all options including
genetically modifying corals and looking
at approaches like this to reduce heat
stress and there's a lot of work that
needs to be done to analyze coral
systems throughout the world to find out
what might work where but these are like
losing our coral systems would be like
losing all of our tropical rainforests
if it were on land so it's actually
quite an important problem so so that's
marine cloud brightening it has some
interesting characteristics in terms of
you know potential possibilities for use
the research in marine cloud brightening
is also of interest to scientists
independent of the climate problem
because the interactions between clouds
and particles are the greatest unknown
and climate they're the biggest reason
that we can't predict climate and
weather and the kind of detailed
experimentation and close study that we
would like to do to know whether we
could brighten them to cool the planet
is the same type of work we'd like to do
to be able to better predict climate and
weather so this research is considered
dual purpose and for that reason it's
actually been slightly prioritized as a
topic of study and so now I'm gonna talk
about the Big Kahuna which is the one
you hear about more often
which is the approach of putting
particles in the stratosphere and this
the concept for this is based on
observations of what happens when very
large volcanoes go off and when mountain
Pinatubo interupted erupted in 1991 it
generated a cooling effect for the whole
planet so if a volcano is large enough
it will send particulates all the way up
into the stratosphere
they get entrained into the stratosphere
meaning they stay up there and they'll
stay up there for a year or more and
this chart shows the change in
temperature so temperatures dropped over
half a degree C and then they gradually
rose back up over the course of 14 or 15
months so penta - boqo cooled the whole
planet and so based on that idea it
might be possible in a much more managed
way looking for benign materials that
are the least impactful on the
stratosphere to disperse particles
around the stratosphere looking at
regimes that minimize side-effects and
using aircraft most likely spreading
over weeks or months to offset two
degrees of warming or more with
particles in the stratosphere and it's
thought that you could do this by making
the stratosphere just 1% more reflective
so a little bit of tweaking of its light
and so I'm going to show you now this is
a simulation using a model that's the
first of its kind in the world it's the
only model that exists that allows you
to simulate a managed regime of
dispersing particles in different parts
of the stratosphere in a regulated way
and this is showing the difference
between the projections using one of the
big global climate models of business as
usual which is the path that we're on
and the projections and these are
surface temperature projections and the
projections of what it looks like to use
stratospheric aerosol and Jack
around the globe and the comparative
result in temperature this simulation
was produced by Simona tomes and yaga
Ritter at NCAR in Doug McMartin at
Cornell and Ben Kravitz at Pacific
Northwest National Labs and it combines
a model of injection into the
stratosphere with the the GCS M which is
one of the major of global climate
models this is version 1.0 and so what
we learned one of the things that we
learned from version 1.0 is that there's
a lot more we need to do to understand
to add in things like more atmospheric
chemistry data more ocean interaction
and things like that but one of the
things that we learned about this
well this before we get to some of the
learning this is a simulation from the
same model that shows changes in sea ice
at the poles and what you can see this
is the business-as-usual projection
where sea ice starts to go away and it
doesn't come back and under the regime
with active sunlight reflection you can
see that sea ice goes away then it
starts to come back and then it remains
relatively robust lee again this is a
model projection and which we want to
know more but one of the interesting
things that we learn from this model
projection was about side effects and so
some of you may have seen in the news in
the past week that there was a study big
headlines that said doing this kind of
stratospheric sunlight reflection will
impair crop growth around the world and
it is certainly true that one of the
side effect risks of doing this is that
affecting the quantity or nature of
light to the surface so that is one of
the things that you would want to manage
carefully if you did it volcanoes when
they go off don't manage that very well
and the study that was quoted was a
study of volcano volcanic data and then
input into models simulating volcanoes
and so I liken it to a chemo
therapy regime where you give everybody
all the chemo and their first treatment
versus trying to manage the approach so
that you minimize side-effects
so what they found when they use the
model of a managed regime was that the
side-effect profile was less extreme
than when you use a model for volcanoes
bless you and and so so that's an
important finding and this is showing a
little bit more about the side effect
profile so I talked about the impact of
light to the surface and one of the ways
that light to the surface gets impacted
is the way that the chemistry of what
you're putting in the stratosphere mixes
with ozone and it turns out that ozone
has a Goldilocks of the only two so
that's the earth likes a certain amount
of ozone in the stratosphere not too
little not too much and so under certain
conditions you can actually get what
they call ozone overshoot so if you're
too little
ozone you get too much UV light to the
surface if you have too much ozone you
get not enough so we want to so one of
the important risks that we have is
understanding the chemistry of the
stratosphere how that affects ozone and
how that relates to light to the surface
and so so that's one of the key side
effects the other side effect that
people are concerned about with these
techniques and these side effects tend
to apply it to marine cloud brightening
too but in a different profile is the
effect on precipitation and overall it's
thought that when you remove a bit of a
bit more sunlight from the atmosphere
and you make it a bit cooler that
overall precipitation will be dampened a
little bit and so you may end up in a
situation where precipitation is
slightly less than it would have been in
pre-industrial conditions but but heat
is about the same and so people are
better off but not quite as well off as
they would have been in pre-industrial
conditions another concern is that you
get a variable impact and so different
people in different parts of the world
have different outcomes and once you
once you've done this in a managed way
it's pretty hard to separate those
outcomes from what happens in nature
so these are some of the side effects
that people are really worried about and
they have to be compared with the risks
of what happens under regime of
increased heat but what we do know is if
we if we can do more research we have a
better understanding of what where these
side effects sit and a better a better
grasp on what our level of uncertainty
is and I'll explain about rare
researches as we go but just to give you
some relative context and I'm gonna
start this off by saying we don't
actually really know how much it would
cost to do this because so little work
has been done but to give you a sense of
the orders of magnitude if we were to
try to go below two degrees by 2050
based on the charts that I showed you
the first number 44 trillion that comes
from the IPCC and that's what it costs
according to the IPCC to stay below 2
degrees using emissions reduction only
now the caveat that by saying you may
get lots of savings in terms of fossil
fuels and other things so I'm gonna put
big caveats on all these numbers and
just say this gives you some sense of
them what is a magnitude and the second
number what it costs to remove co2 is
based on the new kind of optimistic
assessment that you could do it for $100
a ton and based on a $100 a ton which
doesn't quite actually really exist yet
and I put an asterisk here because those
technologies aren't quite
production-ready but based on that
that's cheaper potentially than
emissions reduction maybe not but when
we look at sunlight reflection it's
quite a bit cheaper and I put in here a
loaded cost based on sort of 50 billion
dollars a year with a regime that starts
in 2030
and that's a much higher estimate than
some other people would quote but I come
from IT infrastructure so I know you
need security and compliance analytics
and so on so just to give you a sense of
the relative cost of these things and
where they say and that low number is
what worries some people about this
to be honest so so I'm going to talk now
about what's needed and where we are and
so I look at this problem as a complex
systems problem like a health problem we
have one patient patient is planet Earth
our state of Medicine it's about
eighteenth nineteenth century and we're
in pretty critical condition and so we
have a complex systems problem and
coming from IT infrastructure again you
know what we need is data on the various
layers of the system we need good much
better tools than we have for analyzing
that data and looking at the system in a
variety of different types of ways the
good news is we have technologies that
we have not applied to this problem yet
that exists for other things so the
disruptions in remote sensing drones
surface aerial space most of that stuff
has not been applied to this problem at
all and likewise with computing and
models and analytics so I worked on a
project with ocean climate risk that was
taking approaches to studying complex
systems in finance and IT and applying
them to study ocean climate risk so one
of the ways I look at this is that the
full weight and force of what the tech
industry knows how to do has not been
applied to the problem of understanding
the climate system that's good news
because that's low-hanging fruit so we
could understand understand the system a
lot better and a lot faster and if we
want to intervene in the system I would
argue that we have to and I've talked to
politicians and and people on the left
and the right and what I tell them is
that if you're interested in intervening
in the climate system we have to
understand it much better than we do
today and we have to make investments in
the scientists the platforms and the
capabilities that we need to understand
the Earth's system better it's a
prerequisite for any invention that we
do so that's part of the whole deal here
and in order to do that we have the
mother of all inner disciplinary
problems
so I don't know if you can read this
chart but the disciplines involved go
from nanoscale particle generation
through you know localized weather
systems all the way up to global climate
data and information systems civil and
environmental risk and control systems
all the way into human and societal
operations and the way we make decisions
together as a human population so that's
a tricky one and I'm gonna argue that we
need to do all of the studying that we
need to do in the next decade because of
the timelines that I pointed out earlier
in the conversation so for me the
question is how come how can we
coordinate an agenda to learn what we
need to know about possible options for
protecting ourselves from heat risk in
the context of the kind of damages that
we might be looking at even if there are
only possibilities by the middle of the
century and so to that end there are
some different kinds of exploration that
we need to do technologies we need to
develop the aerosol generation I'll
share with with you guys and I'll talk a
little bit more about the fact that
there really aren't research programs
today there are no formal sources of
funding in this area and to my knowledge
the only place in the world where the
developing aerosol technologies to to
try to perform these techniques and
understand them is here in Silicon
Valley and it's a team that's comprised
of a half a dozen retired engineers
so I'm whom co-invented inkjet printing
in the optical mouse and they've been
working on this problem for six years
for their grandchildren without pay now
that work is likely to move into a more
formalized setting where we can work
more actively on different approaches
and different ways to scale it up but
the technology is critical to
understanding what might be possible and
what we're going to feed into our models
and analytics and so alongside the
technology for dispersion we need lots
of improvements to our climate models
and analytics and we need specific
models and
that look at these specific types of
approaches and I could talk to you a lot
about some of the limitations of models
in our reliance on them to make
decisions about climate for any of you
have worked on complex systems you know
that a big part of the challenge is
looking at the systems in different ways
and there are different ways you poke at
the system and analyze the system and in
climate we've been using primarily
simulations and simulations are
particularly bad at picking up the kind
of complex system dynamics like abrupt
change and so it's particularly likely
that we may be under estimating the kind
of changes that we're facing so we need
to improve these badly and we need to
get more systems people using more
different ways of looking at the system
and then experiments so once you have
this technology and you've done some
modeling work process level studies of
what happens when you release particles
into the atmosphere
how they interact with the cloud how
they flow out into the stratosphere
those are really crucial at very small
scales they can give you a lot of
information to feed into models and
estimate what's going to happen so there
are a couple of proposed experiments or
experimental programs this one is a
picture of the program at Harvard which
is the most well funded program in the
world for looking at brightening the
atmosphere it's headed by a
well-regarded well known scientist named
David Keith it's an interdisciplinary
program that's been trying to look at
the societal aspects of doing this as
well but they're proposing experiment in
the stratosphere using a balloon where
they would release a number of different
kinds of materials only a leader each so
they'll be very lucky if they can
measure what comes out but they're
looking to determine some of the initial
chemistry the interactions with those
different kinds of materials in the
stratosphere and maybe something about
the way they disperse and that would be
the first step in a very long sequence
of studies both in modeling and in
experiments and in data to try to get a
grasp on
whether this would work what material
you would want to use and what kind of
bounds you could put on the wrists of it
so that program is is happening they
don't believe they have a definitive
date for that experiment but I think
they hope to do it sometime in the next
year and the University of Washington is
the home of the program which is not
funded and so consists of researchers
working in the voluntary spare time
together with the engineers who've been
working in their retirement but what
they hope to do is a sequence of steps
that will go from generating a single
plume overland plume over the ocean and
then finally a patch of ocean and clouds
that they would brighten with multiple
ships and try to measure changes in the
reflectivity and that whole sequence
that they would like to do to measure
changes in reflectivity of a patch of
ocean and sky which would be your first
experiment and whether you can brighten
the cloud they think will take 8 to 10
years to do that sequence I press them
on it like well if we have money we can
go faster okay so but but to give you a
sense both of these experiments that I
described are below the level where the
EPA would even engage them for a review
so they don't contain physical risks
with regard to the kinds of parameters
that we have today for putting things
into the atmosphere but people are
worried about them for other reasons
like the precedents that they might set
or the societal forces they might set
into motion but if we want to pursue
these things and I'm very interested
that we have knowledge and information
for society to make decisions about then
there's a sequence of things that we
need to do and and a little bit of that
sequence has started but as I mentioned
today around the world there are no
formal sources of funding for this work
if you are a researcher that wants to
work in this field there is nowhere to
apply for a grant unless you work in
social sciences
so if you want to work on technology or
the scientific aspects of this there
there is nowhere to go there is a
program in China a modeling program that
was actually founded by a British
researcher who married a Chinese woman
so it was not a strategic program in
China but in China they also have the
largest weather modification program in
the world and they recently launched a
rain making effort that's three times
the size of Spain so one of the things
we have to consider is whether we in
Silicon Valley or in the US or in the
Western world decide to research these
kinds of approaches whether or not
others do but to move forward one of the
things that's been missing partly
because there's no funding or kind of
standing body researches in this space
is an agenda is you know what are all of
the things that we need to study and
what does that look like so the National
Academy of Sciences is soon to announce
a study to establish a research agenda
and an approach to governing that
research so that it's transparent and it
has oversight and it can avoid maybe
some of the societal concerns that
people have so this is kind of where we
are and maybe defining an agenda from
there we need to establish research
programs build the ecosystem of
researchers here in the US and around
the world
educating engaged people about what
these things are and ultimately maybe a
decade from now we might have some
information about whether these things
are feasible how we would characterize
their uncertainty around their risks and
whether there is anything at all we
might recommend for for readiness as far
as possible reduction of he so thinking
about things that way there's a bit of a
coordination activity required so we
have the research there are a number of
players involved and the possibility of
exploring these things
on behalf of society our search
community is a big part governments a
really important part because you don't
go to very far and engaging the
atmosphere before government resources
come into play and you don't go very far
before government authority comes into
play so that's an important part and
technology and business and I'm the
somewhat unique in the category for
thinking that the technology industry
and technology people could play a much
larger role and particularly a role in
accelerating how well we understand
climate for those of you from tech
there's a big DevOps gap climate models
and climate data this is the biggest
consumer of computing in the world and
they lack the they lack automation to
make it run on the infrastructure so
that's just a pet peeve of mine lots of
opportunities to accelerate the adoption
of what we know and what we have
philanthropy I believe will will play an
important role in catalyzing things
getting started and in complementing
whatever government efforts do civil
society is really important and a lot of
people have a lot of concerns about this
which I'm going to describe and so the
NGOs and the groups that look after the
overall welfare and justice of people in
the world are really important and media
and the general public and I would love
for media to cover this area a little
bit less sensationally but wouldn't we
all in our respective fields and so what
are people concerned about there are a
lot of concerns and these concerns have
generally been fairly instrumental and
the reason that there is no research
funding for this either in government or
in philanthropy and one of the biggest
concerns is this idea of moral hazard
that beginning to develop these
capabilities are beginning to research
these capabilities opens up the idea
that we can take our foot off the gas in
reducing emissions and that we set in
motion a sort of idea that that there is
an easy way out
I would argue based on my decade of
looking at this stuff that looking at it
closely does not tell you that you don't
need to reduce emissions it tells you
that you've got a very narrow band of
temperature suppression you might be
able to do you and it's absolutely
imperative to stop knitting really
honestly you heard it from me
so so I so I think I think the moral
hazard question is one that that's a
good one to have a debate about because
sometimes that moral hazard comes in as
soon as the ideas out there and more
research may just just be helpful versus
harmful so that's an important one
another one which I didn't realize
coming into the space that that was kind
of close to home for people was the
relationship between man and nature and
the idea that actually these kinds of
techniques move us away from a natural
system versus towards the kind of
natural system that's more unimpeded by
man and that's a tricky one David
Grinspoon who wrote a book great book
called
earth and human hands talks about the
fact that you know the intelligent
species on the planet have been altering
it for a long time even before
industrial times so whether we apply our
intelligence and have to manage it more
actively is a question but that is that
is one that hits pretty hard and then
the other one here on the left which is
also a big one really big one which is
can we move forward even in researching
these things if we can't figure out a
just way to make decisions about them
and I'm hoping that we could convince
people that do those activities in
parallel so that we have more knowledge
as we go and when it comes to the point
of making decisions we've got more
information to base them on but there's
definitely a debate about whether we
should be doing anything at all until we
figured out a just way participatory way
for people to make decisions and it's
partly based on the fact that a lot of
people did not have a say in the
greenhouse gas situation to begin with a
lot of the people that suffer from it
first
and as a side point just because I
didn't raise it sooner one of the
advisors to silver lining is a woman
named joyous tree from India joy Sri Roy
she's a senior economist in India and
she was telling me that it's forecast by
2025 in Calcutta where she's from
there will be no days of the year where
it's safe to work outside no days of the
year where it's safe to work outside and
that would be happening in a number of
places around the world so this question
of justice comes up a lot with regard to
this then we have some on the sort of
slightly different way of looking at the
problem
can we move ourselves into a way of
thinking about relative risk versus
absolutes around climate issues in other
words we may need to expand the
portfolio of things that we're looking
at into things that have more real or
perceived risk can we handle the notion
of relative risk because we know as heat
rises the risk continue to get bigger on
that side of equation but it's been hard
to have discussions about relative risk
and Stuart has the nuclear advocate is a
person you know people on this sort of
eco modernist or eager pragmatist side
of things are frustrated by the fact
that things that are perceived to have
risk are we're unable to weigh them
against the growing risks of he and
climate and finally and I guess this is
my perspective on the problem working
for so many years as I have with
engineers and business people there's a
focus on the outcomes and so I'm very
interested in minimizing suffering and
maintaining natural systems for the next
hundred years and so I tend to look at
the problem from the point of view of
that which is an outcomes point of view
whether that's the right point of view
or the point of view everyone is taking
you know that's kind of a debate but
these are the debates to go on and it's
not hard to start talking about this and
wind up with a discussion about human
nature and civilization and whether or
not we all
serve the planet that we've got so it
gets very furious esoteric very quickly
but we have intervened to solve big
scale environmental problems before so
my parents are from central Nebraska
this picture at the top is the shelter
belt how many of you have heard of the
Great Plains shoulder belt program in
the US few of you excellent
anybody watch my testimony anyway so in
in the 30s in the Dust Bowl period FDR
was looking at what could be done to
address the fact that there was a
desertification going on in the in the
Great Plains in the u.s. that poor
farming practices of the settlers had
basically eroded the land such the
beyond this big Dust Bowl and so they
implemented this massive tree planting
program and if you drive through the
Midwest you'll see these lines of trees
through Nebraska Kansas everywhere and
and they were planted in a 200 mile wide
stretch from Canada down to Texas and it
was a very concerted effort and it was
considered to be very successful and it
was the biggest is the biggest
environmental engineering program in US
history and it happens to have been an
atmospheric engineering program too so
so that's one example and the second
example here is the ozone problem in the
Montreal Protocol and for those of you
at Stanford you know you have George
Shultz there and it was actually
Republicans in office at the time that
the ozone problem was highlighted and
addressed and it was a collaboration
with industry and government that looked
at what chemicals they could use to
replace the ones that were killing ozone
and they perceived it to be an
existential problem and they addressed
it that way so it is possible for
decision makers in society to come
together and say we have an existential
problem across parties and across
boundaries usually it involves some some
technical expertise and scientific
expertise but it is possible to address
that kind of problem and that was also
considered to be wonderfully successful
and there was a recent study in the past
so six months or so I'm describing that
success so whoops jumping ahead to the
punchline so this is a cartoon by Bjorn
Lomborg of where where we might land but
we are an intelligent species and and
for those of us who who are prone to
despair I say look we're all still here
and in and we have wonderful capacity to
to solve and create right and so I look
at it as in this way that we have one
spaceship and all the people are on it
this is our ship and like Apollo 13
failure is not an option so I think that
if we focus we may need to you know
science a little bit of this thing and
pull some additional tools out of the
toolbox ultimately our goal is to get
really healthy natural systems but you
know we we have some possibilities and I
hope you all will support the idea of
exploring them thank you for coming out
tonight
Thank You Kelly so we're we're a bit
late on time so if you just pull out
your stole no it's all good but we so
we're gonna go a little bit over so we
can get a few questions in here and I'm
gonna get the first one I can I get you
a delicious interval so first question
that I want to ask you so you are you're
doing amazing work you know you're
taking on this advocacy role that's so
important in your so it's it's so kind
of factually and project based rather
than just dealing I think I think you're
dealing with kind of the realities of
the situation where a lot of the
imagination goes to the further reaches
of when a global system is implemented
but we are there are so many steps that
take decades to get there that's doing
it
characterized for us so use you spoke to
Congress last year as we talked about
you're speaking to leaders in industry
in a lot of different places as you're
doing this tour who are the people
you're talking to what kind of reactions
you're getting does everyone even agree
that that climate change is happening
with what sort of challenges you're
running there can you just characterize
from your kind of world tour on this
what's what are the types of
conversations you're having with what
types of folks sure so I haven't done a
world tour I've been most focused on the
US and the UK a little bit but I have
spent some time particularly in
political circles in the US and there
are a couple of really important things
I think people should know firstly the
US has the largest climate research
infrastructure on earth by quite a
stretch and all of that infrastructure
and people are still there apart from
the EPA there are six other agencies
with major climate research programs and
they're all intact in fact in the last
budget they got sleigh increases so I I
talked about it kind of like a cake
where you have you know the cake which
is the sort of substantives you know
science infrastructure of the US
and then you have the frosting which is
kind of what we hear about attitudes
towards these things coming from the
administration my experience on both the
left and right is that there's a lot of
concern about climate I haven't met
anyone from any party who doesn't
acknowledge that the earth is warming
different characterization as to how
severely different maybe different
thoughts about what the cause is but if
you're talking about heat stress on the
climate system they're all seeing it in
our state's in their districts they're
interested in it and one of the things
about these kind of technical solutions
is there a way for people on the right
to engage with the problem that's
politically acceptable so they're a good
entry point and yes you said you haven't
gone around the world but I think you
are tracking things a lot and and you
touched on China and I know you're aware
of and I think one of these we talked
about earlier so the total amount of
money in terms of what what's been made
available here in the US and can you
contrast that with with other countries
and then and it specifically maybe a
little bit about China and how you see
them approaching this area so I'm gonna
differentiate between funds for social
science and funds for science and
technology research R&D because in the
social sciences there's a lot more money
to look at the problem and in in science
and R&D very little so the program at
Harvard I think this is public
information they've raised about 10
million dollars today almost all of it
private and unclear as to whether those
sources of money are continuous they're
not strategic so they're not places
other people can go for money in this
area in China this program that they
have which is modeling centric is a
three million dollar initial program so
not very big so we're talking you know
of the of the funds that we know of
maybe in the past several years 15
million dollars generously which
effectively at a global scale is
effectively zero if we look at the
portfolio so that is a big you know for
me one of the key areas
to address is it wouldn't take much in
terms of a small increment in the
portfolio to add a huge amount of
knowledge impossible optionality in this
area I'm sorry how much of that was
social sciences versus actual the 15
million is technology R&D I think the
social science is amount I don't have a
good cumulative amount for that but
that's ongoing then you would
characterize that as what's the social
discussion around climate change or
what's the impact the categories usually
referred to as governance and so it's
looking essentially at oversight and
control of these things a lot of the
societal questions around
decision-making so law so there is a
program at American University at UCLA
at Potsdam in Germany and Oxford in the
UK and I'm sure I'm missing some and
then there are their researchers and
there are a number of foundations where
you can apply for grants to study
governance of sunlight reflection or
geoengineering but you cannot apply for
grants for the science and I want to
just just a little bit of housekeeping
you mentioned end car and CI SL can you
just say who they are and also you
mentioned slack and slacks close close
to here but can you just explain yeah
what they're doing in car is the
National Center for Atmospheric Research
and there are the agency that they work
in is the National Science Foundation
NSF and you can think of n cars big
locust of climate modeling in in the US
the other agencies that are salient are
Department of Energy Department Energy
does a lot of work in the troposphere
remember they did a lot of work in the
atmosphere around nuclear bombs and
things like that and they're a big site
is Pacific Northwest National Labs which
is the locus for climate research within
the Department of Energy and so
Department of Energy is also relevant
because they run the supercomputing
systems that these big climate models
run on as far as slack that's the
Stanford Linear Accelerator Center and
they're only tangentially related to the
problem because they're working at the
atomic and subatomic level but they're
just undergoing an upgrade so for those
of you who don't know what they do there
they shoe is sort of x-ray a photon beam
at molecules and atoms and they take
pictures subatomic scales and a
billionth of a second to determine
what's happening in those basic
processes and they're about to upgrade
it so it'll be ten thousand times more
powerful and they can research
everything from energy to materials to
drugs and and they have teams of
researchers coming through from the
round-the-world who are expected to get
Nobel prizes for what they learn and so
when you see things like that you think
okay it's just a matter of time but
that's what slack is and I recommend
going for a visit if you can so let's go
back to the model so we talked about
models all the time the model says this
the model says that and we always talk
about models plural so you you're in a
great position to unpack this for us
how many models are we really talking
about do those tend to be overlapping
and showing the same thing is there
great contention I mean we've got a
couple other speakers on this topic and
sometimes it seems like certain
researchers are very bought into a
particular model and kind of it's almost
like allegiance to that model and and
that that might even be a problem in
terms of researchers coming together on
certain things I don't know but it is
how would you kind of characterize that
and are they they tending to point in
the same direction or are there kind of
fundamental differences that we should
know about so that's a big topic yeah
it's okay I'll give you 20 seconds all
right there are a couple things I'll say
because because I understand models and
simulations coming from a different
direction and so some of the things that
surprised me about climate models is a
lot of the a lot of the policy that's
based on climate model work and a lot of
the generalizations that are drawn from
climate models come from an average of
models and so they will take the average
of the range of model findings now if
you're an engineer you're looking for
the most accurate model not the average
of all the models right you're very
concerned with the the most accurate
reflection of the system but in climate
model work
they're as concerned about replicability
so can models be reproduced by somebody
else and sometimes that leads them to be
more simplified then they are of the
specific representation of the system so
they want experience so there are a
couple of these dynamics the average of
models the replicability factor over the
sort of accuracy factor that people
don't realize say you know these models
are they're not always optimized to be
100% reflections of the actual system
they're they're optimized to study
things in different ways when you take
an average of all the models and Ken
caldera just published some work this
year about mapping recent data from you
know different aspects of the Earth's
system on to model projections and
saying the most accurate models were the
ones that gave the worst projections and
so so they're they're good at showing
what's happening right now but not good
at showing the future is that from so
they're all not equally good firstly but
we're treating them as if we can average
them out right and so we may not be
doing enough comparison to data with
these models so that's the first point
the second point is that simulation
models use processes countless millions
of processes and complex systems don't
lend themselves very well to process
level analysis and the things those
models tend to miss are the things where
one plus one doesn't equal two in equals
three where the part that where
something happens that's bigger than the
sum of the parts of the system and one
of those kinds of things is abrupt
change so you know with that coral
system suddenly died well that I she
collapsed that is specifically and Phil
rash who's the chief climate scientists
at Pacific Northwest National Labs will
tell you that the models are
particularly poor at abrupt changes in
the system
in theory that could happen the other
direction to like a new technology comes
online and changes for sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah in the human systems the same
way and because I started my career in
economics it's a commonly known problem
and economic forecasting right and you
keep trying to find different ways of
coming at it and so one of the things we
did in the ocean climate study you
always look at more probabilistic ways
of looking at the system and the
relationships of things in the system
and so we need to make sure that we're
we're using all the tools that are
disposable for how you look at complex
systems not just particular kinds of
models and that when we are using the
models that were that we're constantly
testing them against data and we're
looking for the models that are the most
accurate reflections of the real system
versus the average across different
approaches and thanks for patience
everybody we're not gonna have time
obviously there gonna be a ton of
questions I know you are gonna stick
around right as always she's going to be
here and we really encourage you to come
up here we're gonna be here for a while
so we'd love for you to come up and ask
your question Joe we're gonna get a
question for you in a second I've one
last one I want to ask you and it's
about a number you put up on the board
for 750 billion in 2030 so remind us of
what this if we spent 750 billion then
we would get what outcome by 2030 so
firstly I don't know if you caught in
the slide but I put two question marks
next to me because my meadow point is
that we really don't know yet what it
would cost and so I use a much bigger
estimate than other people are using
which is 50 billion dollars a year in a
production level of scenario and 50
billion dollars a year assuming that we
started in 20 that we did our 10 years
of research yeah so that what I wanted
to ask you was walk us through how we
get to that what does that mean if
that's in 2030 we get that outcome what
does that mean we have to start doing
tomorrow or what are what are the
assumptions that are built in to so the
assumptions that are built into it means
that tomorrow we start defining a
research agenda and we start scaling
funding of researchers and different
pieces of that agenda over the next
decade specific to sunlight reflection
and these sort of active interventions
and alongside that we're making
investments in improving our ability to
understand the climate system so we're
upgrading the supercomputers we're
adding more cloud computing and we're
moving these next-generation remote
sensing so we got higher resolution
higher frequency observations and we're
keeping all the scientists employed and
we stopped insulting them and so we're
doing those two things in parallel over
the next decade and then a decade from
now what's the most likely thing is
people come back and say well we're not
sure but here's what we learn here's
what we think might be feasible here's
how you would characterize the
uncertainty around it here's how a good
character I there's just risks
here's what you might think about making
investments in to scale up and then it
may take another five to ten years to
scale and so so am i right to say the
the assumption is investing more money
in the next year or so like on the
millions of dollars sort of front to get
this started and then how long does it
take from there to actually having not
just because we have lots of theoretical
lots of lots of images and lots of
models but actually testing something
how many years is it from today before
even doing a small-scale test depends on
what you mean by a test okay so if you
take cloud brightening for example which
is a really cool example because you
just want to put some mist literally Oh
seawater into the air the first step is
to do indoor testing and they like to
use something like the NASA Ames hangar
and simulate different humidity and wind
conditions and do a bunch of that and
then from that you might have an
apparatus a sprayer a research tool that
you can use and that would take the
first round of doing all that stuff
might take you two years it's where you
get a research grade sprayer you could
got on the ocean then you go out on the
ocean then you do single plume tests and
you need some drones or airplanes to
measure the chemistry and things that
are happening and then once you've done
a few of those you go out and do a patch
of ocean and sky and by that time you're
at eight years maybe so you could
accelerate that stuff and I know you're
shaking your head because you're
thinking you and plus you need to
replicate it a lot and so because you
have seasonal variations you have
regional variations you have all kinds
of things going on so yes you would want
to accelerate that but right now there's
a lot we could learn even in
single-digit millions or slightly low
double-digit millions over the next
couple of years just getting researchers
ramped up and I wouldn't recommend for
example doing like a moon shot or a
Manhattan Project because right now we
don't have a research base so we need to
kind of prime the pump get some
researchers working in the field get
some of these smaller skill activities
going lots more modeling work done and
then see what makes sense to grow so was
there a question the questions in the
back chair did you have somebody sorry
okay all right well let's yeah
there's there's one okay what can you
say about the relative time frames so
both the problem and the solution so if
you are too aggressive with the
particulates presumably it can get out
of control or you mentioned a little bit
with the moral hazard if to what extent
the the problem is already growing out
of control did you say a little bit
about to what extent there's data behind
how either of those so I think that the
for me the meta point is like there's a
decade of work to do before you would
consider doing
anything at a scale that would impact a
climate or people at all and that you
would have tons more information to say
whether that was a good idea or not and
so where you sit on the moral hazard
side is you know whether the activities
associated with generating more
information generate more hazard or
whether the information helps you and I
think that's a question for debate all
right a quick question and then hi my
name is Wayne I won't you my throat
the politics of getting people to
recognize how serious how literally
deadly serious this problem is for all
of humanity and the rest of living
things in the planet is my concern if we
have the will like we did when we
entered World War two and we mobilized
our economy we could change things
possibly in a way that would have an
effect on this how do we bring about a
political awareness that that is the
level of problem we're facing it's
actually worse than that but that's the
kind of level we have to get people
convinced that this climate change is
anthropogenic climate change is the
worst existential problem humans have
ever created so I agree with that
and and I would throw out the idea that
proposing solutions like this and having
people say no this is where we are are a
bit of a wake-up call in themselves and
so it's possible that dampening that
idea tells people that well hey you know
we still so my experience isn't talking
about these solutions it's an eye opener
in terms of the severity of the problem
and it's really important to talk about
that severity I think sometimes that
discussion is muted by the fact that we
don't want to find ourselves in a
position where the portfolio of the
things that we hope will work no longer
will and so you know opening up this
discussion maybe allows us to be a
little bit
candid and realistic about where we
actually are potentially but my
experience too is the these more
technical approaches are a safe space
for having the conversation for people
for him some of the more traditional
ways of talking about the problem don't
work and so opening up that dialogue and
saying look this is where we are with
regard to heat regardless of how you
think we got here what you think we need
to do about it and then opening up that
dialogue so I'm you know for me I'm here
as an optimist to say hey Society has
done this before I we did in World War
two we're all in this together and by
the way I have a pet peeve about this
idea of winners and losers I think that
has one of the biggest moral hazards in
the climate equation is the idea that
there are winners that there are people
in Silicon Valley investing and building
bunkers and not investing in solving the
actual problem and I don't think anybody
wins and so the idea that there are
winners and losers maybe creates
complacency in developed countries and
with the very people who could push the
problem the hardest and so we need to
talk about the fact that in what's
coming here there are no winners really
any win that you think you have is very
transient and so you know if we can all
get the sense that we're in this
together
like you said I think that's very key
but I think it's possible and we're
gonna we're gonna have to close I I just
wanna I want to invoke a couple things
that you said at the beginning the look
at those kids
and then the fact that it's grandfathers
who are one of the most active people
that are doing this it's a reminder what
we think about it long now we're trying
to be good ancestors and what does that
mean it means the decisions we're making
today whether in technology or
consumption or what-have-you
there are there other people in the room
and they're the people that are going to
come after us so we are making decisions
that they're gonna have to live with and
we need to weigh their needs and the
balance with it Kelly thank you so much
for a great talk
[Applause]
[Music]